on est lundi et squeeze sort une vidéo
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
squeeze aujourd'hui on se trouve pour la
suite d' alien isolation effectivement
en est la diège sur une vidéo c'est tout
simplement parce que j'ai envie que ces
vidéos sur aliens soit un bonus par
rapport aux 4 vidéos que je mets en
ligne chaque semaine que les gens qui
apprécient le let's play et ben ce soit
tout bonus pour eux ils ont le double de
vidéos est que le gens qui n'apprécient
pas ce let's play et ben ils ont le même
contenu qu'avant ils ont quelques vidéos
par semaine sur autre chose qu'à
l'isolation voilà l'explication s'est
terminée voilà on se retrouve devant
donc la sauvegarde alors je peux pas
vous promettre que j'arriverai cinq
lundis jeudis et samedis à mettre un
épisode à la désolation en ligne mais du
moins j'ai ça irait alors je vais
augmenter le son parce que finalement
c'est comme ça qu'on aime les jeux
d'horreur or passent par là du coup la
fonte faire quoi ah oui du coup on à
l'outil pour ouvrir l'époque sont
maintenant donc on pourrait celle là
voilà c'est parfait retirer la tâche
oh non ça sent pas bon thématiques y
avait ça qu'on n'a pas du tout une
cinématique devant bouge pas un geste je
ne bouge pas maintenant autour de toi oh
[ __ ] tu arrêtes tu sais tu peux je
suis gentil je suis mignot regarde genre
marteau
mon nom est replay et que sordo replay
de l'extérieur d'un vaisseau ya pas de
vélo je suis ici maintenant si voilà ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle
bah oui parce que ça craint pas mal ici
c'est toi qui craquent par une explosion
à tous ceux croyant quoi j'ai vu sa
diffusion
aulas mais ça c'est bien le dernier de
nos soucis
ouais c'est quoi alors le point de
castres la chaussure des stations être
une passion incroyable nature du combat
tueur abbas et la vienne oui d'accord je
veux aller manger
axel axel tu veux bien m'aider à les
retrouver oui elle moi retrouve mes amis
s'il te plaît tu as l'air de connaître
les environnements je veux dire pourquoi
je gagne quoi moi et tu tapes direct on
place sur le vaisseau tu t'en sors
vivant mec mais comment je sais si je
peux te faire confiance
as tu le fais où tu trouves le centre
comme à les emmène chez moi et rend
moins bâclé c'est ton jour de chance
c'est toujours de chance mec sans nous
tu serais mort maugard artigues bobby
est tu m'appelles pas poupe et voit là
bas c'est bien il donc là il va s'il
veut amener à la tour de contrôle pour
qu on contacte le vaisseau sur lequel il
ya notre pote qui est encore dessus en
train de piloter
oui je parle très français c'était toi
qui me suivaient la fallait bien que je
garde mes distances
on n'est jamais trop prudent mettez une
sorte de gros pervers tu me suivait mon
gars alors on y va c'est bien des belles
plantations des bénéficiaires mais
arrête de des schizophrènes wow n'est
pas là pour chercher les embrouilles
dans tous les sens alors machette jeunes
cherchent et ringo c'est juste une paire
de connard salue on a d'autres choses à
faire ou on aime pas de connard john à
dire on nous dit si hockey balle ovale
propre et je suis désolé tankian balle
est ce que vous prenez avec vous
l'ascenseur éventuellement s'il vous
plaît et éventuellement j'ai dit enfin
c'est pas éventuellement est pas allée
bien vous faire un plus tard en regarder
c'est cette ambiance là quelle
incroyable avec cette petite fumée douce
comme ça rétablir le courant bah c'est
parfait et arrête de me regarder chelou
[ __ ] et on travaille chez un vieux
machin encore le boîtier spécial fois
doigté spécial moi j'ai le doigté comme
ça ok bah c'est toi qu'elle doit était
finalement en place à temps comme ça
appuyez sur le bouton
mais arrête de me saoulé il est pas mal
ce mec qui me regardent bizarrement et
met la pression et bien blazers ah non
c'est parce que tu crois mon gars je
vais accomplissez pouvoir te yeux vides
en dessous alors la ribot de l'ascenseur
ok alors il a insisté sur le fait qu'un
psychopathe un tueur c'est tout ce qu'il
veut nous dire on sait pas ce que c'est
bon je pense que c'est la lienne situe à
certains même c'est des conneries c'est
un frein on ferait mieux de chercher une
sortie qui est complètement dingue
il n'y a aucun moyen de sortir de cet
endroit au moins ils s'orientent dessus
hein
alors on leur tire dessus bon bah c'est
par la refermant la gerbille et l'amener
à ripper on y va on y va l'homme chauve
allait bien à ben voilà ça s'est
débrouillé ok je comprenais pas je me
disais bien elle c'est parti ici pour
axel dans les conduits à l'excellent je
te suis de voir cette phase en gros plan
c'est génial d'un petit conduit comme ça
tout fin à l'écologie vae
voilà quand même c'est justement vous
pas que j'ai la tête dans ces faits
s'ils l'ont laissé pour un peu d'avancé
j'ai mis les sous titres comme ça vous
pouvez lire parce que j'aime mais moi je
n'entends pas très bien savoir on se
retourne tous et à toutes les autres la
peur ça on les gens concernant ces gens
qui font des remarques
ouais bah oui bon ça oui j'ai bien vu
même toi tu as fait une butée dont aussi
des singles et je me dis ça sa baraque
hockey et ben je vais me servir mon gars
on commence par les biens ou pas soirée
mousse non c'était l'un dans l'autre ça
la soirée mousse il est vrai il aimerait
donc là on est carrément dans la piaule
d'axel c'est génial alors ici ramasser
la lampe torche
c'est une lampe torche ah oui ok qui se
met à qui se met autour de la tête
mickaël avec un casque
waouh pourquoi y'a j'ai compris que je
ramasse une lampe torche et on met la
pression tout de suite quoi si génial
vega ne pas lui mais n'importe où j'ai
pas trop envie qu'on se fasse opérer sa
marche aux piles away [ __ ] c'est
conduit les piles c'est par là tu te
calmes butin hop l'aller on y va oneapp
de la partie iib personne du vaisseau
acceptes tu restes non je vais sauver ce
conduit y en a un où quelque part par là
j'essaie de marque dessus pourquoi
l'oublier ça marche
eh ben on va trouver tous conduits et ab
non mais c'est moi qui donne au [ __ ]
c'est pas celui-là mais qui s'est passé
bah non c'est nulle part sa semaine dans
un ventilateur pour ce faire décapiter
gratuitement donc effectivement là bas
y'a rien passé par là c'est celui-là
mais [ __ ] où elle est aujourd'hui
c'est ça et bah bien remettre des fesses
axel le show elle fait peur on a regardé
le
oh tu vois je gère fugère je gère
fougères plus jamais ça excellent sinon
on va te pousser un ventilo et tu vas
mourir parce que là ça va les conneries
en bas on n'a pas besoin d'axel on a
besoin du pistolet d'axel c'est pas la
même chose mon gars allez on est là on
te suit de près je t'ai entendu un truc
et alors et alors on continue aussi au
nom non effectivement va se détendre
on va devoir je pense quoi dans les
et les faire s'évanouir peut-être pas
les tuer mais ok pour la mettre en
sourdine ici et n'allume pas cette
torche interne mais qu'on passe au
milieu de six autres personnes comment
on fait quoi gardez vos oeuvres à portée
de main ou vrai feu dès que vous voyez
un communiqué automatic quoi on tombe au
moment où il faut tirer à vue quoi
génial créer une diversion pour
distraire les pierres ok aucun gros là
on doit accéder à la porte qui est là
bas
sauf qu'ils aillent en plein milieu
qu'ils soient armés qui vont tirer à vue
et donc il faut faire diversion les
attire un endroit pouvoir passer c'est
par ici
hill hospital générateurs c'est ça est
un le générateur au plat et l'autre il
va tous les tous les français je fais
quoi moi je fais quoi moi mais vous
venir la longue à la personne dans les
parages mon gars ils sont là mais
comment je fais accès les trois bateaux
mais je pense que j'étais bien caché aïe
ça fait mal bougé aïe ça fait mal ben
oui bah oui mais bien sûr si il vient et
des voitures y roulent moins souvent dit
et tu désactiver jeu court direct on
puisse y mettre un petit temps à
comprendre ce qu'est ce qui se passe
sous les lumières c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
axel je suis là mon amoureux mauvais je
suis avec toi ils m'ont vu mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait axel axel accès
l'afrique face [ __ ] ça il est décédé
votre allié n'a pas survécu bah oui il
faisait un statut forcément à remettre à
plat je suis débile je suis mais il ya
des bills
oh [ __ ] le coup moi je partais je
partais faire du parcours avec eux voulu
se faire sa place au plat allez bonne
chance pour votre générateur un aaa à je
suis diabolique
ok je sors high tech
elle sépare taxe elle encore mon gars au
camp y assure n'a réussi à fuir avec
axel witsel
moi mes goûts et à tous quand l'un des
chaumes à moi ok on y va qu'est ce que
c'est que ça ramassez détecteurs ou non
peut pas sortir encore à ça me plaît ça
ça me alors axel guide nous non mais max
et emme mais ça va pas là ça n'a pas où
est ton traitement là contre la
schizophrénie chez ba [ __ ] j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir se par isna [ __ ] des
sous mais bien sûr que non ça va pas se
passer comme ça hop là et même un [ __ ]
encore une histoire du courant abbas
juge de la jirs foire ils ne seront pas
réduits à merde vous couper le jus au
nom j'ai l'ombre il faut qu'on active
les vieux construit en même temps son
lauréat frire je me charge de celle ci
je m'occupe de séquelles l'autre côté
oui bah bien sûr tu as sûrement d'une à
bouger mon cul axel un [ __ ] ils ou le
têt le même pied tantôt axel est dans
tes cheveux même ta [ __ ] cheveux il est
plus là alors à eux
il va se passer il va mourir h23 il va
se passer un truc pas bien lui rien et
voilà
accédez à travers trois axes à dos axel
jeanine axel j'arrive conte d'amour
[ __ ] oui c'est bien tran et vous j'ai
chopé sept enfants et nous leur clic
gauche ou qu'est ce qui se passe mon
gars auxerre mais un faux pas chez
casbah oui bah c'est axel c'est la
course poursuite qui est engagée al clp
je profite en couple on s'aimera jusque
dans l'au-delà à mon ami axel cours
actuel à ok cinématiques au nom tapis
tissés teinte a buté se tissent cui
longs c'est moi qu'il allait tuer ben
oui sauver la wii wii play ça suffit le
shaq fu conscience note mais oui il faut
sauver un peuple elle a un jeu comme
franche que je veux tu es folle à la
confiance en lui
j'ai en tout quelque chose oc l'aliène
axel axel j'en ai sûrement là haut c'est
le sens qui est super acide leçons de
ces la vienne c'est ce [ __ ] dalian dix
mois que son gun est tombé par terre dis
moi que si on gagne est tombé par terre
des mois et des mois qu'à son gun ya pas
son gun au nom et au nom atteindre la
gare de entre deux transits j'avais pu
parler ton pistolet ue c'est par là ok
on y va on y va on y va au fond ce manga
rond fourons suis papa rousset mais
crois moi est un alien à montcuq je vous
jure que je vais pas me taper mater dei
6 1 je vous le dis c'est là pour toi
ah mais je me fais peur donnant un coup
faut que je passe par là non non
là on voit juste nifle aliens jusqu'à il
est juste là haut en train de faire un
sudoku poser à voit la taz égaler les
aliens dégage un alien va t'en aller
bien ça c'est fait pour être la pression
mais ça marche pas sûrement ça ne marche
pas et ça ne marchera jamais je prend
même pas la peine de regarder derrière
moi
on est au dessus de ça
bon eh bien quoi l alien gary les
vallées peut vouloir jouer à tu veux
dire je tiens par la barbichette avec
nous sauf qu'une claque d'alien passé
plus de tête d'autres maury be happy
allez ouvre toi
le vaisseau et une ride mais ça ça
marche quand même c'est génial à mes
oreilles [ __ ] a loupé trois voilà
merci [ __ ] et lorraine du temps ce
qu'on a c'est comme un petit mais trop
mignon c'est génial tour c'est parti on
y va voilà et voulu quand je lis que met
la pression pour rien la vienne il était
posé il était entrain d'hiberner et
voyager en finit cet épisode sur cette
magnifique prise de métro où il nous
mène
je ne sais pas peut-être vers la lienne
pour offert un mot croisé peut-être
qu'ils jouent aussi aux mots croisés
merci d'avoir regardé comme d'habitude
j'espère que ça vous a plu ci soutient
n'hésitez pas aimer les vidéos du lait
explique que je le sache voilà moi ça me
plaît beaucoup parce que le film malien
j'avais adoré d'ailleurs les voir si
vous suivez l'expliquent vous ne l'avez
pas vu on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle danse égyptienne voit le cliché
à tout le monde
pis